I want to be something more than Shaq
see the Shaq guys gonna fade away
because you got Steph Curry and all
these guys stepping up the shot guy will
fade away at some point in time but dr.
Shaquille O'Neal won't be around forever
and ever
dr. Shaquille Rashaun O'Neal welcome to
you how are you sir good and I call you
doctor because unbeknownst to a lot of
people you hold a PhD in education yes
so true tell me about the franchises
that you're involved in my favorite one
right now is Krispy Kreme our
relationships with 24-hour Fitness five
guys and you know but my favorite one
right now is a Krispy Kreme and why is
that because I like donuts and Charles
Barkley loves Donuts he's my biggest
customer Nova cryptocube is just a
fabulous darling I was introduced to it
in college and been in love with it ever
since
so right now I got a few friend Fran
choices are looking to get more I want
to be a wanna be a large part of that
business so I was reading about your
relationship with Carnival and they
called you the CFO it was confusing
because usually that's a chief financial
officer but for you it's a different
title what is it it's the chief fun
officer if you're not hurt know what CFO
oh really well no one else tag you're it
that's my job to bring awareness to
people about how fun Carnival Cruise
Line is I admit I used to be a hypocrite
about it I lived across the street from
the terminal and all I saw driving by
was a big ship with a bunch of windows
so I assumed that's for old people
it's boring there's nothing to do but I
was riding around one day and I said let
me go check out one of the ships that
was one of the best things ever saying
my life
restaurants activities for the kids full
court basketball court swimming pool
nightclub I had I was I was amazed so I
had a me
with making convoy I said I I don't
think the people know what you roll them
went over there let me let me be the one
to tell them because again when you like
back in the day if you say Cruz to me
I'm thinking bro I'm not now that's for
old people not doing that but it ain't
for people it's for everybody and it's
affordable and I stayed at a lot of
luxury plush hotels in Vegas that's the
same thing talking about the rooms did
the decor everything is amazing what was
your first investment my first big
investment once it was Google I mean I
had a lot of little minor investments
that you know people will come and say
and we're gonna do some pinstripe
jackets with the wit look at that yeah
with the with the King of England crest
people are gonna like it you give me
$100 and I gave you a million in a year
I did a lot and stuff like that that
never worked out so one day I'm sitting
playing at the Beverly Hills Hotel and I
hear these two gentlemen talking about
Google search engines and one day your
phone's gonna be there so you type
anything and it comes up and I was like
oh say that again oh hey how you doing
Shaq come over here listen to this boom
boom boom boom I would like to invest in
this my god hooked it up when we
invested and I forgot all about it and
then I read the article and everybody
else read an article about the big hit
that some of the early early investors
received when you look at the perfect
pictures it looks like I'm at home
saying do this do that do that today
it's just you know being in the right
place in time and just you know and just
opportunities coming so you still have
to have a skill for being able to weigh
those opportunities how do you know who
to trust my skill is if something comes
across my desk and I don't believe in it
won't even look at it
oh so I guess that gut feeling no it's
just one I can't lie to the people right
and - yes oh god feeling like my
favorite story I want to just respect
anybody but after my first championship
Wheaties my people say man I want you be
on the cover of Wheaties I said I can't
do that
I said what do you mean brother
breakfast champions I said don't know
what it tastes like never gonna taste it
what do you mean
I said well frosted flakes so all would
be my first option if you want to talk
cereal business with me in Froot Loops
den fruity pebbles period ain't nothing
to talk about when I do business has
never about the monetary aspect it's
about changing people's lives letting
people you know understand that you know
you can still have fun so that's what I
wanted to do I wanted to be like hey you
don't know us on this ship I do let me
show you let me tell you and by the way
not expensive I know I just told you we
got 50 60 options but guess what this is
the price of bail so that's what I'm
doing now along the way
do you see your opportunity you go back
and have a conversation we're always
said he's got a lot of great restaurants
on their.i welfare people like chicken I
don't see the over chicken spot this is
what I'm doing would you like to be
involved yeah I never thought you're
yours gotta have you know business
conversation with them
so I'm launching my first big chicken in
2020 on the ship radiance that's gonna
be our first one but again like whenever
I do business it's not about the money
I heard Jeff Bezos said one time when he
was talking he said he makes his
investment and based on if it's gonna
change people's lives and once I started
doing that strategy I think I'm probably
quite a Drupal what I'm worth now let's
talk about the future you've had a lot
of success in the business world you've
done movies you've wrapped you've done
all kinds of things but what's most
important to you now I have a lot of
dreams and aspirations first one is to
be sheriff somewhere that's my next big
dream second one is law school third one
is to open up children schools K through
four there's a school around the corner
from my house I love it
I call it a no problem school all the
stuff we got going on and I live in
South Deep South Georgia will not stop
but south of Atlanta all the stuff we
got going on I'll ride by the school
every day
black-and-white kids playing and hugging
and kissing Spanish kids all running
around and they all know me as uncle
Shaq I'll stop by and I'll play with
them
love that law in in owning a law firm is
part of your plan right yes I will be
what sparked that interest but what
sparked our interest is having a little
bit of success in owning things I want
to be a lawyer I don't know but I would
like to educate myself on what it takes
to become a lawyer take the bar pass the
bar and then go back to my teamwork
concept let me get a law firm I'm gonna
give me a hell of a point are boom I
mean I'd like to get five or six lawyers
we put them together get one guy done to
me I manage all of them we'd be very
successful that's one of the dreams I
have I'd like to sit down and just make
up stuff that I want to do and then at
some point go for it when you went to
LSU it was a tough front people were
hacking you what was that night when
said was tough it was was something that
I I relished and I always looked at it
it's a sound respect can't play you
can't guard you two of my teammates
added to me which makes 301 we still
can't stop you now we got to beat you up
but you know growing up with a drill
sergeant and being a football player at
first he loved people know football was
my love so I always like contact I
always like bringing the pain and I can
receive the pain so that gave you that
toughness thing yeah definitely
toughness underneath it and you know and
actually helped me make a great business
decision because again my parents were
stress education so my whole plan was to
stay for years graduate didn't go pro
but the first time I had to make a
business decision and you know taking
all those business courses and reading
all those books my favorite book is two
dummies guide to starting your own
business
a friend of mine named Gino Moreno gave
me that book he said you're gonna be
you need to read this book so I'm
sitting there and I'm saying to myself
okay if I get hurt this year from people
tackling me in the air the lawyer to the
love den will provide me million dollars
but Derrick Coleman just signed for 30
million in 88 economically it's gonna go
up 15 20 percent so I could probably ask
for 40 50 million do I stay and get the
1 million if I get hurt or do I take a
jump at this 40 million and then come
back to school so that's when I started
at the age of 18 years old
I started thinking like a businessman
and I think it was a great decision as a
kid how did you relate to business did
you see yourself as a business person in
no no I was I was taught by scare
tactics to to become a businessman and
then uh you know because again I didn't
want to be one of those guys and our
family relied on me and everybody looked
up to me my grandmother used to tell me
at our early age you won't be the one
the one for whatever my you're gonna be
the one that just make life easier for
everybody and I used to tell her you
know a grandma when I get rich I'm gonna
buy you big old house in Newbury Church
and I was and I was one of the first
things I did so to not be one of those
things I said to myself okay all right
I'm making a lot of money now what do I
do with it
metal Jim and one time here on a piece
of paper and said it's $100 ripping I
have $50 he said smart people invest
whatever real estate with this 50 but
didn't you have 50 left but he said the
wealthy people take half of that 50 now
you got 25 and you put you put that away
and this you have fun with the cars the
jewelry whatever you want I started
doing that and then when I started going
to LA I started seeing the things that
magic Johnson was doing the community I
said okay this is what people started
talking about and then I started jabbing
into it you know my first big purchase
was 40 24 hour fitness
we did that and then we did some real
estate
redeveloping
about Newark New Jersey we did with
devilled about four or five restaurants
in Las Vegas did a couple local car
washes
got a couple annuities what's so
attractive about the franchising
business it's just you know again
partnering up with another reliable
excellent brand you know being in
business with people and just you know
owning stuff magic Johnson said to me at
18 years old when our first mother first
time I met him cuz uh
he had an event and they clapped Magic
Johnson Newcomb I was killing it and
magic poofing at this I said it's okay
to be beloved by the fans but at some
point you want to start owning things
and then 18 years old I had no idea what
he was talking about but as I got older
and moved to LA and saw he moved around
the community as i okay this is what i
have to start doing you were criticized
earlier in your career for diversifying
but now that seems to be your strengths
criticism to me is a double edged war
you can take it and listen to it and
fade away or you can listen to it find
some truth in it and better yourself but
I only take crews only take real
criticism from my panel
mother father Dale Brown my parents
Jerome Crawford College meeting and
Perry Rogers test my panel the only ones
can affect what I say and what I do ever
so then when I hear something growing up
with a drill sergeant you can't hurt my
feeling no work can hurt my feelings
I've been in San Antonio that Germany so
they know word you could say to hurt my
feelings
so I'm programmed to go alright you're
doing too many rap albums you know you
got swept three three rounds in a row
for the last three years all right fall
back on the rap just fall back on that
let's see what you can do Oh
championship boom fall back on the rap
again another championship boom we fall
back on the rap and the movies and the
commercials alright three in a row so
rather than go
you listen sometimes what the people are
saying specialist people you respect
people you don't respect you only listen
above his people you respect like why
hurts because I like you in are
inspected you said something I wouldn't
get it bad that y'all were just reminded
a couple of time close my eyes and
listen all right he has a point
he has a point and that's how I do
criticism self because you have to take
advantage of opportunities everybody
don't get these opportunities I never
wanted to be a rapper I never wanted to
do movies thought about it dreamed about
it so when I got drafted Arsenio Hall
kept calling me hey man I want you to
come on the show but it always goes back
to the story I told you earlier my
mother said make him remember your name
I don't want to come on your show
Arsenio and a $5,000 suit and tell you
corny stories and have you laugh we want
to do that because that's the format but
at the end I gotta make them remember my
name that do something different let me
rapping my favorite rock group Arsenio
then you can't rap let me show you did
it Bo Momo record companies called the
next day right now I don't want to drive
looking at 10 million three-album deal
saw opportunity I said okay but I don't
want to do island by myself let me deal
with all my favorite artists and you got
to pay Marcus what everyone all right so
now I'm trying to help them I'll get
them some money to deal but I was my
first opportunity so then I'm walking
around and I like and I see a guy Billy
freaking he said oh you know why I said
no sir my name Billy freaking I've
directed exorcist
my man election at my house when we
started talking I got a project for you
sir
you'll do a movie man I'm not acting oh
well good thing view is you got to play
a basketball player I don't know if I
can do that we'll pay three million
dollars what me so this is about
learning about sitting at home go I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna do that
by the time these things just come up
it's widely known that your relationship
with your mother as cloaks and the one
thing that really struck me in prep for
this interview was learning also about
Phillip
your father and
he wasn't just tough on you he was also
tough on the people who were working
around you as well it seemed like tell
me about him he was a drill sergeant it
was a drill sergeant he was a major
disciplinarian and he was a major
high-level juvenile delinquent growing
up northern New Jersey and he knew what
the surroundings could bring he knew
that if I didn't follow the right path I
could end up a follower as opposed to a
leader so his mind said I'm gonna do
whatever I have to take to make sure you
go down the right path and I thanked him
for it every day I saw an interview with
your coach Dale Brown from LSU and he
said that Phil told him once if I think
it's time for blacks to go another
direction and develop intellectualism so
they can be presidents of corporations
instead of janitor so they can be
generals and in the army instead of
sergeants and so they could be head
coaches instead of assistants if you're
interested in my son's intellect we
might talk something what inspired him
to be that way and how did that impact
you well because he knows that education
could could you know bring up a lot you
know education something that can never
be taken away from me I have to retire
from basketball you have to retire from
NFL you have to retire from being a
rapper you have to retire from being an
actor but if you don't have education
what you're doing all that you've been
one of those stories that we all know
about is very this ashamed that you know
60% of professional athletes after
they're done they have nothing well he
made that statement because at the time
I was a terrible basketball player six
nine thirteen couldn't play couldn't
done couldn't dump but it wasn't looking
good for me so the only only way I could
probably go to college and get an
academic scholarship so he was really no
he didn't want no CDs no B's if I didn't
give it any it'll be gonna be trouble
and you know it
as I don't care what you're doing life
if you're educated man
they can't take anything away from
mm-hmm and you were in Germany at the
time as well four years in Germany as a
kid how did that influence you I tell
people all the time that either the
Karate Kid sort of life the things I
went through and my childhood prepared
me to become the character known as Shaq
for example born and raised in the
projects of Newark New Jersey had to
move to Germany learn how to deal with
Europeans left there had to move to San
Antonio you know you deal with everybody
including Hispanics leave there go to
Baton Rouge had to learn how to deal
with cash in so the point I'm trying to
make is it enables me to deal with all
people I speak every language Shalom
Salaam alaikum what's up big homie how
you doing sir I speak every language to
everybody and that's another great thing
that my father differently moving every
four years I got to learn different
cultures different religions and just
learn people when you think about legacy
a lot of self-made people they worry a
lot about whether their kids will have
the work ethic that they had to be able
to get to where they are is that
something that you worry about in legacy
obviously is a big deal to you because I
used I use the same talk tech as my
father used education first because I've
tell them all the time look we don't
leave another one'll basketball players
I like to have engineers lawyers hedge
fund operators like this it's a 60-yard
young or any direction you know want to
of them want to go the basketball route
I have two older ones I have two young
ones with a very very intelligent I
don't really worry about them but I
don't stress what I did I just dress
education and I'm also stress in
business I'm telling them now think
about what you want to do when you grow
I can get you there but you want to you
know take it over the top like I lived
in Bell here a long time see a lot of
rich spoiled brats riding around
they filled in title I see that and
based on what I saw Micky Arison doing a
lot of other friends who made the kids
tile from the bottle exactly what I have
to do and my kids are beautifully smart
like they're so smart sometimes I said I
don't think we need to go on the Maury
Povich Show because there's no way I'm
your father you got all this because I
listed my parents I'm very successful I
wasn't one of those guys that made up
1900 on the SAT or 40 on the AC T I
wasn't one of those guys I've only come
to academics she talked about so you
know from you to listen to to people who
saw the vision that I didn't see follow
that vision to a tee and good people
around me I would say I'm a lucky
individual
[Music]